[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
like the CIA says you do not exist
[Music]
[Music]
they'll always need men like us those
who are willing to do
[Music]
with others cannot
[Music]
we need to fight back
let's hunt
watch and learn brothers
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone hello and welcome to the
community reveal of call of duty black
ops 4 on behalf of Activision Treyarch
and the entire call of duty black ops 14
it's great to be here with you thank you
all so much for joining us listen we
want to start where it matters the most
with you our players black ops has been
a nearly 10 year journey and you have
been there every step of the way with us
so I want to thank you all for your
support and your trust throughout thank
you
now that Trust has allowed us to take
all our risks over the years and that
support has allowed us to grow black ops
in some new ways now you've come with us
on this crazy and insanely fun and
sometimes mind-bending ride from
nurturing and off-brand Easter Egg
called zombies into a full-blown
phenomena to introducing you to twisted
stories and unforgettable characters you
played and that you played with -
bringing you new ways to play compete
and watch multiplayer throughout this
journey
Treyarch has never shied away from
introducing something new or unexpected
to Call of Duty and breaking with
convention if we thought you would have
fun with it and that tradition continues
yet again black ops 4 is a living
example of what we do best as a studio
we set the bar high we challenge our
assumptions and we take nothing for
granted and we rethink everything about
how we make games which leads us to
today
black ops 4 is a game that gives you
more ways to have fun with your friends
than anything that we have ever created
it's the deepest most replayable game in
our history
now let's yeah let's face it that's
saying something cuz you guys well you
guys have played the hell out of black
that of black ops series we're inspired
by your passion for playing our games
together together online for months even
years and today today is where we begin
to break it all down for you this is a
special day for us and one we've looked
forward to for a long time and as you
can imagine we got a lot to share so
we're going to show you more at this
reveal than we ever have
this is a business as usual this isn't
business as usual and that starts now
with how we're approaching black ops for
multiplayer universe and who better to
do that than Dan bunting and Lord
Vonderhaar
[Applause]
[Music]
hey David what are you doing I gotta
update my twitter name to lord
Vonderhaar
and done we could either show me how all
right thank you everyone for coming
today we are here so excited to tell you
finally about this game that the team at
Treyarch has been working on for the
past few years and for those of you who
have not been with us for one of our
past multiplayer reveals we are going
deep today before we tell you all about
black ops 4 multiplayer which is set in
a narrative world between black ops 2
and black ops 3 we're just gonna show it
to you can I can I take this line give
my all right knock yourself out all
right here is the worldwide reveal
trailer for call of duty black ops for
multi player live
[Music]
- and now not in the presence of Bravo
secure
pushing on me
[Music]
every shot counts
when we strike team deploy
building Vatican
guys shooters fine
targets
[Music]
excessive glowing life
[Music]
eat this
[Applause]
I lost count of how many times you
killed me in that video so black ops 4
represents our most ambitious
multiplayer to date a delivers grounded
combat tight gunplay an authentic
military feel and of course the fluid
and responsive controls that you know
and love all routes in the most refined
tactical team experience that we've ever
delivered it's a deeper and more
rewarding experience that will be played
for a long time to come alright wanderer
let's just get something out of the way
you guys ready can you thrust jump
can you wall run
[Applause]
can you confirm we are 100% boots on the
ground
look as we know you love the fluid feel
of black ops 3 combat so the question
that we always start with is how do you
create a more grounded and tactical
experience but do it without slowing
down the player
so that's pretty easy right we didn't
stop believing in guns up so in black
ops 4 where you still move and interact
with the world in a really fast and
fluid way and you can still keep your
gun up while doing many of the other
things in the game like throwing
grenades and using equipment activating
scorestreaks and mantling and what's
better than doing all of those things
while still being able to fire your gun
and it's doing this while firing your
gun ruin returns and this time he
brought his special issue equipment the
grapple gun that only he can equip and
create a class so Road is a specialist
with those unique ability to close the
gaps and get to the enemy faster and the
combos that you can pull off when you
grapple to grab slam have been making
the highlight reel inside the studio and
we can't wait to see just what you do
with this
so specialists are back both new and
some familiar but totally reimagine
because each specialist brings special
issue equipment that delivers unique
capabilities to your team to reinforce
the tactical gameplay without slowing
down the player and you'll hear about
many of them throughout the discussion
but you would be fooling yourself if you
thought that they were the main
characters of this show that's right
because black ops is and always has been
first and foremost about weapons and the
gameplay around them it's no different
with black ops 4 however with black ops
where we've made more improvements to
gun systems then literally the entirety
of black ops 1 2 & 3 combined this just
show is how serious we are about weapon
systems at Treyarch we've designed each
weapon as though it's a character in and
of itself which means that we a PHA
attention to every single detail hot
barrels are gonna ooze smoke muzzle
flashes are gonna burst and light up the
room bullet impacts our map
they connect the player with the game
world around them and weapons for the
first time have real 3d tracers which
both look and feel incredibly awesome
but they also serve a gameplay purpose
because they let you know where the
gunfire is coming from and animations
have been overhauled to make that feel
that you know and love that much more
responsive bullets will actually deplete
as you expend the magazine but that's
just the start
this is a small example of the details
that we pay attention to our weapons on
the design front black ops 4 is going to
break with tradition by giving each
weapon its own set of attachments now in
the past attachment sets were shared
across weapon classes but this is
important to us because unique
attachments are all about making the
gameplay of weapons stand makes what
makes me each weapon stand out from each
other we're also bringing a new category
of attachment this game it's called
operator mods operator mods the ultimate
expression of a guns profile that's
going to expand its capabilities in ways
that go beyond that core functionality
you're gonna see here the titan LMG
laying down some heavy heavy suppression
fire that suppressive effect is only
capable through its operator mod it's
gonna distort and disorient the enemy on
the other side of it
now I'm excited to say that weapons are
further to something defined by another
first in franchise history today I'm
here to tell you
black ops 4 will be the first game in
our history to use a true predictive
recoil pattern system this allows you to
constantly make micro adjustments while
aiming and shooting this means that the
gameplay of each weapon is learn about
there's a path to mastery that is
rewarding for new players and veterans
alike this is by far our biggest
investment in the weapons platform in
combat systems that we've made to give
you the most rewarding and visceral
experience by pushing the
state-of-the-art on weapons visuals
animations and sound effects weapons and
health are two sides of the same coin
and you can't change one without
affecting the other and black ops 4 adds
some tactical depth through a change in
the healing mechanic healing is no
longer automatic now players manually
trigger their healing process with a
dedicated button and that becomes
essential to your gameplay loop as
reloading the weapon after a firefight
and we like this change because it
creates a tactical decision point that
simply didn't exist before so you can
disengage from combat and heal up or you
can rush an unsuspecting opponent who
may be healing herself and these changes
create a more tactical pace to the game
where instead of simply losing to the
person who shoots first you can actually
survive a gunfight with smart
maneuvering and this means you spend
more time in the part of the game that's
the most fun which is the combat so
aggressive players still feel rewarded
for being aggressive and tactical
players can actually choose when to
disengage and look for a better
opportunity to strike our journey into
the health mechanics has evolved it
doesn't end just here let me introduce
you to crash and crashes a medic and
this means when his ability is ready to
use you can actually restore and give
bonus health to players for a limited
time and crass is just more than a medic
he also distributes a salt pack which
resupplies team and no doubt the folks
at home are already breaking down that
empty trailer and they've already
figured out what this one's lying so
we've taken a completely fresh look at
the health mechanics of a black ops
multiplayer game to insert tactical
decisions and some much-needed pacing
into that gameplay
so so far we've talked about some really
fundamental building blocks of what
multiplayer and what makes it awesome
you got movement
weapons health systems we're gonna take
it up a level to situational awareness
situational awareness covers the gamut
of what you see in here in the game from
the mini-map to the sounds that your
footsteps make on different surfaces
we've experimented with all sorts of
modifiers that have impacted this over
the years but in black ops 4 we embrace
situational awareness is a fundamental
feature to the game we're introducing a
new system called the fog of war and
only the parts around the menu around
the plate on the mini-map the fog of war
reveals a radius around the player and
his or her teammates as you'd expect and
meet players are going to reveal their
positions when firing a weapon unless
they're suppressed and many of your
favorite score streaks like UAVs
encounter UAVs are still gonna do what
you expect them to do but what the fog
of war does it creates more
opportunities for teammates to
communicate and work together for the
win
now I'm going to introduce you to
another new specialist his name is recon
recon is an expert in situational
awareness his special issue equipment is
called the sensor Dart when he shoots
the sensor dart into the world it clears
a large radius around it that both he
and his teammates can see and it helps
you to locate enemies he also has vision
pulse which makes a return from black
ops 3 but this time around it's a little
bit different the whole team gets the
benefit of it so with effective usage
these mechanics together can be a clutch
way to snag victory from the jaws of
defeat situational awareness is as
important to the gameplay loop as
weapons health and movement and as with
the other fundamentals were giving you
the players access to these top tools to
control your own gameplay loop the flow
of combat is how movement and weapons
and health and situational awareness all
come together in the head-to-head
gameplay spawning pathing level design
all of these things impact that flow
you might remember Sarah she has a tact
deploy and this is a team wide spawn
beacon that allows Seraph to command
offensive control over that flow of
combat for a period of time
and this is torque torque is the master
of disrupting that flow because he can
lay down razor wire and create
deployable and improvised cover with his
barricade and one last one over the
years we've experimented with the idea
of area-denial in various ways and in
black ops 4 it's time to stop playing
around fire break makes his return and
makes area-denial a part of that
gameplay loop his special issue gear the
reactor core allows him to do just that
and firebreak can even trade his own
health to extend the clock on that time
so we've combined the best designs and
how level spawning and flow control work
together to influence the gameplay loop
and then we place those tools not in our
hands but indeed the hands of you
through the specialists and the story of
black ops 4 is not one of a single game
in development but rather the combined
journey of the entire last decade of
black ops and you the community have
been with us every step of that way
every game that we make is an
opportunity for us to do better to
continue the dialogue that we have with
you and you know that we listen you
expect that commitment from us and this
is why we do what we do so I think we've
covered all the details we've pretty
much given away the secret recipe to our
multiplayer experience what I miss just
one little thing just want to tease for
our competitive community and that is
the return of lean play
league play is a fan favorite and we've
combined the very best parts of it and
we're going to deliver it for all the
players of black ops 4 as Mark mentioned
in his opening remarks we're doing some
things a little bit different in this
year including how we tell stories in
each mode throughout the game now we're
delivering more narrative and character
depth and multiplayer than ever before
and we're also gonna give new and
returning players the ability to learn
and master each of these specialists and
solo missions these missions feature a
series of fun and fast-paced trials to
give a hands-on introduction to the new
returning specialist while exploring the
stories behind their identities and
their backgrounds inside of a black ops
narrative now with each game the black
ops players have spent more and more
time in multiplayer and it's important
to us that we go bigger on that
experience and expand the narrative
universe around it here is just a
glimpse into that universe not bad not
bad yourself
no one gives a [ __ ] about you
you a number an asset
a pawn in someone else's game they've
been manipulating you
watching you
[Music]
exploiting you
they'll leave you for dead
so here's the deal alone you can put up
a fight but together you can start a war
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think it's time for us to talk about
zombies you're normally everyone
especially all the zombies fans out
there we know who you are
those of you who remember zombies is a
bonus mode hidden in call of duty world
at war have been with us from the
beginning you've watched as our undead
have grown to become an essential part
of the blackops experience the story
that we began a decade ago is as much a
result of your work as is ours
zombies has always been about that
shared journey both through our
characters and the tightly knit teams
who and friends who joyfully compete to
be amongst the first to uncover the most
latest and deepest secrets just as with
the rest of black ops war we've gone
back to the drawing board on zombies
rethinking and we could give you more
ways to have fun with your friends than
anything we've made before the zombies
community has always been our North Star
which is why we took everything that
you've taught us and put it on the table
for discussion about where to go to next
10 years after it all began we're about
to begin a brand new chapter in the
zombies story right here together and we
couldn't be more thrilled to reveal the
details with those of you here in
attendance and the many fans tuning in
worldwide
joining me to share more about this new
adventure is Craig Houston our lead
writer
[Applause]
hello so over the years what are the key
aspects that is driven the zombie
storyline and fan interest is mystery I
sense that you're entering an unknown
world where anything can happen when we
say anything we mean anything you know
stuff like giant robots mythical staffs
interdimensional time travel and we
monkeys they explored when you throw
them maybe your training monkey you'll
be fine basically all the things that
you zombie fans consider normal we've
explored many different time periods and
a variety of fractured universes knows
the perfect time to start fresh and let
the zombies community discover a whole
new world together
black ops 4 marks the beginning of a
brand new storyline separate and
distinct from the ether story a new
world with new characters and new
enemies drawing from history both real
and mythical black ops 4 zombies will
introduce us to a new enemy an ancient
order hell-bent on transforming the
world to fulfill the nefarious agenda
against them stand an eclectic group of
all new player characters unexpectedly
thrust together by their shared
experiences with each one bringing their
own colorful personality skills and
unique perspective to the team you know
what it's probably best if I just show
you this is 9
[Applause]
you draw Hugo
[Music]
was not
[Music]
Green
[Music]
will transport
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for your safe return
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
garbage bruno diego ensure our new cast
we know them and we can't wait for you
to get to know them too okay a
mysterious new world sinister villains
and engaging heroes and a riveting story
of chaos all forms just one half of the
equation it's the what we'll play now
let's talk about the how how will play
the game during the development of black
ops 4 we routinely ask ourselves the
question how do our fans like to play
well after taking down literally
thousands of zombies it turns out that
you've earned the right to make up your
own rules and play the game the way you
want to play it so we're going to
provide you with customizable tools and
social systems to evolve zombies into a
evergreen mode for daily weekly monthly
and yearly engagement zombies also now
boasts custom mutations over a hundred
different customizable options will
allow you to play the game your way
changing the fundamental rules and
systems of the gameplay experience
things like zombie speed health train
ability type player damage magic box
functionality and much much more and
since the zombies community loves to
compete with each other we're also
introducing the black ops authenticity
stamp system this will give players a
shareable code stating exactly what was
achieved and with what options as I'm
sure you can imagine this will help
third party high scoreboards and other
kind of custom competitions no one likes
cheats especially me on the subject of
custom competitions we're also
introducing limited time created
challenges that we're naming callings
which will regularly introduce new ways
for you to play the game and set the
stage for ongoing seasonal content and a
few themed experience surprises well on
the way and as we give our fans more
power on ways to play we'll aware that
zombies can sometimes be
a little bit intimidating to new players
especially those who like to kick back
on the couch and play solo the good news
is that black ops 4 zombies will also
include bot support meaning you can
enjoy the full narrative experience that
comes with co-op not got a buddy play
with let our AI fight alongside you want
to mix it up even more we're introducing
a new mode called zombie rush a brand
new mode simplifying the game experience
to create a whole new tempo of gameplay
perfect for welcoming people into the
zombies universe and enticing challenge
for grizzled veterans alike we're also
reintroducing difficulty levels and an
in-game tutorial to introduce place to
the mode in a less stressful way for
those of you also choose to have to have
the path of most resistance you can
crank up that difficulty all the way up
now speaking of stress we've already
seen our four new heroes during an era
of utter brutality where no-holds-barred
winner-takes-all combat wasn't just the
rule of law but society's favorite form
of entertainment but zombie fans
wouldn't be interesting to see them go
somewhere nice somewhere luxurious so
where they could have a good time it is
my pleasure to show you a glimpse of the
second of our day one zombie experiences
welcome to voyage of despair
[Applause]
[Music]
lady Mackendrick maybe at a higher class
than you are used to
mixing with her her Bruno my French
friend the lady will be so lost in my
eyes and enthralled in my tales she
would not even notice when I make my
move
[Music]
timing as always is everything while you
and maybe Michaela head off to do
whatever it is that you're going to do
sure will collect Sookie allowing us
access to the millionaire suite well we
will deal with any unwanted guests and
when you say deal with I have to ask how
I will not sure how you say char wolf
its Eve okay and with you so far but
what did you call there pipe things
you're looking for a pneumatic Hughes
used for the conveyance of small
packages throughout the best they will
carry out some prize down the cargo it
really should be quite exciting
[Music]
hmm and after the detonation that's
where I came in given that the artifact
will be securely locked within the safe
dare I ask how you plan to get through
two inches of solid steel I got just the
thing a mechanism of my own invention
what does it do
it opens things
No obviously your father made some
enemies during his troubles that's a
pretty big understatement if I may
interject I think you were about to ask
if Miss Rhodes expected us to encounter
any opposition it's possible likely to
lose value boys are we to Secours I'm
also just the artifact we're not thieves
we'll go with him all that stands
between humanity and the forces of evil
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's what's happened so that's what
happens when you unleash the zombie
horde somewhere nice okay was the
Titanic but it should have been nice
trust me that bloody great icebergs be
the least of our characters worries
there is so much more to talk about and
this really is just the beginning we'll
be revealing a lot more later this
summer where we we shall share further
details on other never-before-seen
goodies on our road to release thank you
[Applause]
friends we're not done yet
you've seen a taster of nine and voyage
of despair but that's not all the
zombies news we have for you today we've
already said that black ops 4 is the
deepest most replayable game in our
history so it's my great pleasure to
reveal that for the first time ever we
will launch with three fully fledged
fully loaded zombies experiences on day
one
we've seen a taste of what's ahead in
our news story but let's just take a
trip back through the ether one of our
all-time fan favorite maps told the
story of four lost souls trapped in an
eternal purgatory desperate to break the
cycle here is a small peak of black ops
4/3 zombies map
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
where are we going
[Applause]
[Music]
nice not like I wasn't having enough
nightmares just in my day-to-day I have
to work with those people
up listen on the big dis very put it
really simply for you this is a super
serious year for us for black ops for on
PC and we're excited to share that we
have a completely dedicated team with
our friends over at B Knox and they're
making the most robust most refined most
customizable PC shooter experience that
we've created and we're also excited to
announce that black ops 4 will be the
first Call of Duty title ever released
on Blizzard Entertainment's bat on that
platform now while working very closely
both with the dedicated PC team of beam
ops as well as Blizzard to make sure
that this is an absolutely great
experience for our PC players let's take
a closer look black ops 4 is really a
celebration of our community and
something we've wanted to do for a
really long time is focus on PC has its
own unique lot or give PC gamers what
they deserve this version of the game is
custom built for the PC and I think
that's going to show through in every
part of it
we've developed a really strong
partnership with Phoenix in addition to
lizard who have been tremendously
helpful in bringing the game to the
battlenet platform and that's a first
for the franchise
those of us that Blizzard have been
friends with Treyarch for many many
years when it came to working on
overwatch we consulted with Treyarch on
a number of features it's the first
first-person shooter of Blizzard has
ever made so hearing their advice really
helped us build out our game and it's
really exciting that we can welcome them
onto the battlenet platform because call
duty is a cultural landmark with all the
features of battlenet I think it's gonna
be pretty amazing what black ops 4 is
gonna have to offer
is going to be fully integrated with all
these social features on Battlement
you'll be able to add friends talk with
your friends see them playing other
games party up and interact with them
in-game we're gonna be able to talk to
players across blackops
4 into overwatch which should be pretty
amazing
[Music]
PC players expect a lot of options they
like to customize their gameplay
experience exactly how they want it
I be not we have a long history of PC
development and so the PC community is
always in the back of our minds we're
really talking about making sure that
we've delivered on what they wanted for
the black ops tank we've always had
dedicated servers and this game is no
exception
they provide the performance and the
security there are pc players me
we are testing on the widest assortment
of hardware possible to make sure the
largest number of people can play and
enjoy black ops 4
we really wanted to tighten up the
gunplay mechanics and make the movement
system feel as smooth and as responsive
as it possibly can there also has been a
whole redesign of the UI flow and we
have made tweaks to how weapons react
things like recoil weapon knock-back
so that for a keyboard and mouse player
it's easy to get back on target
blew of uncapped frame-rate gonna
support 4k HDR ultra wide monitors it's
going to have great scalability options
so everybody will be able to optimize
for visual fidelity you've seen the team
here get rejuvenated and excited by this
idea of bringing the game to PC in a
much bigger way than we've ever done
before
[Music]
check off recon requesting attack
chopper crass still ain't even lead to
the point
[Music]
[Applause]
black ops 4 is the game that lets you
play with your friends in more ways than
ever before and we all love black ops 4
that combat experience but imagine if we
take that experience you know and love
and we spin it on its head and we drop
you into a large massive world where you
have to survive to be the last man
standing
assist pause here for a minute I don't
have to describe to you how Battle
Royale works these games are no secret
we play them too but for us to even
consider this kind of experience it had
to be unique and done in a way only
black ops could do now we are doing this
but we are doing it the black ops way a
survival game with the best most refined
mechanics in the world
our signature controls and gameplay
systems and the kind of fast-paced
action that only Call of Duty can
deliver all in the biggest map that
we've ever made over 1,500 times bigger
than nuke town and this is just the
beginning we're bringing to bear ten
years worth of black ops universe
features that's your favorite characters
your favorite weapons and the most
iconic parts of your favorite Maps and
we're putting them all in one place a
crazy collision of fun and then we're
going to let you navigate that world
with land sea and air vehicles
this is something that you have not
experienced before
let's keep it rolling do you remember
your CIA handler Hudson or maybe you
remember that very first very sweet rcxd
kill the numbers Mason what do they mean
or that time that when you partnered up
with Rezanov for revenge
and which of these multiple endings did
you experience with the Menendez or how
about that one time when you work with
your friend woods to take the hind now I
should probably mention this one to your
favorite zombies casts weapons and gear
to this is something totally new
this is doing battle rial the blackops
way this is blackout
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
there it is the game that's been
designed for you the black ops community
it's the deepest most replayable game we
have ever made across the three pillars
of black ops for multiplayer zombies and
our new mode blackout alright look it's
all about having fun with your friends
right more fun than you've ever had
before
black ops floor doesn't have a
traditional campaign we're weaving
narrative into each of the modes and
we've added unique ways to play solo and
multiplayer and zombies regardless of
your skill level so if you're a veteran
we're get ready to test your skills and
for those of you who just want to ramp
up on your own we got you covered too
this is a game for every kind of player
it's a game that's built to last for
years to come and we can't wait to play
it with you so thank you look I want to
give a shout out to our friends at
PlayStation thank you guys so much for
this incredible hardware setup but you
guys are going to experience here today
and thank you Playstation for your
partnership with Call of Duty we're
excited for what's ahead of us on behalf
of everybody at Treyarch and all the
developers as well as Activision and our
partners a massive thank you thank you
to everyone here thank you for coming
from far away it means means a lot to us
and of course to those of you watching
from around the world it's not going to
be long we'll be back don't worry before
we're sharing more with this amazing
community again now let's check out that
multiplayer trailer one more time before
you're getting your hands on it with it
next door let's take a look at black ops
4 multiplayer
take care of the one
now not in the present Bravo secure
on me
every shopkins
we stripe team deploy
when Strix
in Vatican
shooters
marking targets
so much
since it going life
eat this
pre-order now and get access to the
private beta
[Applause]